is prime minister viktor orban's
political director he joins us now to
respond bush thanks so much for coming
on boy they it's so interesting out of
all the i mean there are literally
cannibals in charge of some countries on
this globe you have a country of 10
million people in central europe it's a
small country they spend so much time
hating you what do you think that's
about
so hello tucker it's uh so good to see
you uh actually since
2015 when from one day to another
400 000 people
tried to cross our borders illegally and
we made the decision to establish the
fans
and try to protect our borders and
maintain or at least regain law and
order
we are under constant heavy pressure
from the globalist
elites they think that if somebody is
speaking against mass migration that he
or she should be racist or anti-semite
or or whatever
it's crazy but
but this is
our policy is based on common sense
people are our people are very proud as
you mentioned we are a 1 000 years old
nation we are in the middle of europe
but culturally we are an island we are
very proud of
our history our judeo-christian heritage
and we want to preserve it in that way
and uh to do so you have to be able to
protect your borders it's so simple
what's interesting is that the reality
of hungary the experienced reality when
you go there i mean it's basically
america
i mean it's a very moderate place with a
more balanced for your press than we
have that's for sure
and this caricature that is some kind of
rip that it's china
i mean that must have that must affect
you living there you see these
descriptions of your country that are
just insane they're disconnected from
reality
yeah you know you immediately you
immediately realize that these
accusations are are politically
motivated meanwhile the people who are
living there they are very wise people
and my experience is the same here in
the united states if you speak the
ordinary people they they know what is
good for their country and they know
what they want to
reject they are just not satisfied with
the current administration
or current elites
let me give you one example we are the
neighbors of ukraine so currently we are
hosting uh
1 million uh refugees for ukraine some
of them are saying some of them are
going forward but we're talking about
the 10 million country but everybody
knows that those people are
are fleeing from war so there is no
problem with them meanwhile from the
southern borders illegal border crossers
from from from from other civilization
from from other parts of the world they
want to cross the country and and march
through it and start a new life
somewhere in in europe and the ordinary
people they can differentiate they get
they know that on one hand you have to
be welcoming to the refugees and you
have to say no
to illegal border crosses it's so simple
as i mentioned it is and and inherently
moderate i i it's shocking to me that
cnn aired something like that i'm i let
me apologize on behalf of american media
thank you bless orban good to see you
thank you subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight